hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil
village
insert obligatory distractible podcast
promo
i guarantee that we can make you laugh i
guarantee it
you listen to distractible right now i
guarantee you're gonna walk away with a
laugh and if you don't you never have to
listen to an episode again
but i guarantee you if you're looking
for a laugh
why not go check out distractable link
right down there in the description
i promise you will make you chuckle
we'll make you breathe out your nose
real strong and then i'm gonna go save
my baby now okay
where am i headed this opened up but i
don't remember this being
locked before in fact i remember coming
through here
unless i'm horribly mistaken
hello why did one of those close
hello why why
why yeah whatever at least i got a
snipey
am i going back to the castle oh oh
what's going on what's going on
it's very much the happening mark
wahlberg what's
happening no what
no way hey can i
use a crank on this
hell yeah i can
good thing all the tools are universal
in this town actually that might make
sense if there's only one person that's
able to make the tools they might make
everything just fit
and what's in a box number one
money i don't need money wait where's
this go
okay does this lead to that fish
this lead to that special fish
special fish hello
where am i going i'm really unsure about
all this
special fish special fish
okay hey babe uh
do you remember oh it is you baby
babe it's the back door into your place
babe
baby rescue you know i'm really sorry we
had that falling out between us but i
think that we're stronger now than we
ever were
i think that together we've really hit
our stride
if only i could find that knife that uh
i slipped and accidentally
jabbed into you this looks vaguely
familiar there's something
there's that picture
photo of a phantom fish there's
something about it i don't know if this
is exactly
here but i also there's a few different
dock areas i don't even know i don't
think i can go into this water anyway
so it's got to be water that's enterable
if anything
hello anybody here bang
a kabumi oh boy
i yearn for the day when i open that up
again and it's lady dimitrescu waiting
for me to grab me by my throat
i know she's coming back i know that's
happening just gotta find out when oh
i can't hi
oh yeah bring it around almost
keep going no not quite yes
hey stop it
okay or i'll just teleport through it
that's cool too i guess
oh come on this is the most i hate this
hey okay
that you uh listen okay
didn't know that worked that way oh
you're just gonna die no
you get the super death
thank you for that i hate you
you're not even gonna give me anything
you suck so hard
money what good is money money is
exactly
why does you also want the super death
come back
[Laughter]
all right so why am i here why am i here
again
why why have i been cur oh
i know what i need to do
light it on fire yeah okay come on and
now come to me
come to me come come to me come
come come to me this way
any minute take your freaking time i
guess
come on before you fall over and die
come on
yeah bang
thank you all right more
oh my lady
[Music]
my lady milady
and some magna mammal that's so nice
that's so nice that's so goddamn nice
thank you
and i'm incredibly intelligent did you
guys know about my giant brain
i talk about my giant brain a lot i'm
distracted
in the description below whatever your
favorite podcasting happens
i'll give you anything i'll give you
anything if you listen to it maybe you
don't even listen to it maybe you just
download it
that's all you gotta do just download
it's all i'm out of here
time to go back the way i'm supposed to
go and face off with heisenberg
apparently he's the most powerful of all
of these
children but all of them seem to be kind
of chumps
so i don't know where the power comes
from oh what's down here
we yeah they all seem to kind of be
chumps except for lady dimitrescu she
seemed to be the strongest
most capable most beautiful evolving
most powerful really just respectable in
every single way
oh that is definitely a pond that is 100
upon
fierce fears
yeah yeah yes
our finest fish and you not so fine
was that your papa and you too yeah
come here you only hadn't sold that
other fish
yeah that was really dumb on me if not
of selling it but to be honest the
the food menu didn't appear until after
i sold it
i would have kept on to it but i didn't
know
i didn't know nothing i didn't know
where am i going
this is definitely not the way that i'm
supposed to go i don't think anyway
maybe it is who knows weird
okay hello
hi
okay oh that is crunchy oh
it's an antique coin from the resident
evil 7.
dna sequencing complete 99.95 percent
match to delve
mute to my seat the deviation of 0.05
can presumably be attributed to
artificial changes by humans
which means this is probably the source
further investigation into how the
connections manage to find and extract
the mold
is needed wait i didn't get all that the
fungal colony is spread out under the
entire village
when you take the baker incident into
account the hosts of the mutimi seat
are part of a network consciousness says
if that network is linked to here
then we could assume this organism is
here is data storage
if that's the case then what data is
miranda after
that seems like some conclusionary leaps
i don't know about all that but sure
whatever
sure wish i could actually use a
flashbang all right
is this it no there's something else in
here what do you got
there we go
what is that even for what is this for
a w870 what's a w870
what's a w870 i don't even know what
that is
sounds cool
well time to go hunting bam
oh bam oh
bang
thank you for your contributions good
thing i stocked up on all this
valuable
[Laughter]
that's gross okay well i'm not gonna
comment on that at all
and neither are any of you comment
something completely not about that
tell me about your day how's your day
going
is it just starting is it just ending
has it been bad has it been good i want
to know about it
literally tell me anything besides
having me dwell on whatever the hell
that was
oh did i oh no i got everything all
right let's go back up the river
i'm thinking that uh now i need to cross
to somewhere i just know that i'm not
supposed to be here
am i supposed to be here was there some
other way down there am i just going in
a circle
lixie and if i am cut into the future
and call me an idiot
thank you so i went down this bridge
i came across here originally this would
just lead back to castle dim and doom
and dome
oh the statues that's right ah
of course i
well that sounds ominous hey what's up
you want to gobble it
gobble these
giant shells there you go i did the
thing
seems like a weird ceremony that
requires a lot of modern technologies
for you to be able to do what you're
doing now
oh
my baby built a bridge
well that's cool oh
goodbye then oh oh
yeah oh
oh okay yeah this is fine
yeah it's fine this is what you would
call good there's definitely a secret
somewhere in these elevators they always
hide them
but i'm not gonna be able to find it so
i'm not even worried about it
but like a goat okay yeah no this is my
stop
don't worry about the kid even it'll be
fine just get your ass across the bridge
okay i'll get my ass across the bridge
thanks for talking about my kid that way
who's the one that pulled it to pieces
i'm gonna leave now okay uh heisenbergy
ah ethan winters
welcome thank you i think you'd make it
past
daughter moreau but i suppose you
survive worse back in america
i like you yeah
rose and miranda oh come on
in don't worry it's not a trap
i trust you what are you planning
i legitimately don't think it's a trap
hello
hi what's up how you doing in here
hey how's it going what can i do you for
we're gonna do you for we're gonna do
for hello hello
hello
mind if i take your flute
what the hell what the hell
truth hurts
let me guess you're thinking take me out
like the others and then he gets to go
and save rose right
i'm healing my daughter look
you got this all
shut wrong [ __ ] hole
sorry about that what a nice guy
take a seat
listen ethan you're being played
what are you talking about you think
this is a game
i said [ __ ]
lady supersized [ __ ]
ugly ass psycho doll an ammonic freak
don't you get it it's a test
to see if you're strong enough to be a
part of miranda's film i don't want
to be a part of miranda's family neither
did i but here we are
and i'm next in line right kill me
move up the chain well [ __ ] that
i don't give a damn about your personal
issues
i just want to fix my daughter so do i
do you have any idea how powerful a kid
is even miranda scared her
last time you freaked i swear to god
together we go save rose and we can use
her
to grind miranda into beast my daughter
is not a weapon [ __ ] you
last chance you don't want to find out
what's in that hole
i'll take my chances
you're a few i'm such a badass or i
could have not fallen and i don't know
shot him in the face or something
no i want to want to be down here with
whatever's going on here
it's a fan oh it's more
hey my bullets are precious oh
okay propellerhead uh oh okay all right
dude i'm gonna go yeah i'm gonna go
this ain't exactly one of those uh whoa
whoa ethan winters
can i crouch can i crouch thank you
i'm sure there are collectibles that are
happening all around me no it's not
still be a fool
okay cool where am i now
man those gears are kind of bent out of
shape that don't make any sense
yeah what was that thing i don't know
russ is crap you think i could just
reach my hands down and start scooping
and yet no okay where am i going i see
yellow here
uh usually this would be where uh
you know clamber but i ain't
clamber there i clamor thank you for the
clamber
dude oh
okay well i got no there's probably so
much rusted scrap in here
and there's probably some actual like
goody goodies in here that i'm not going
to be able to find
good thing i attached that hand real
good
hello oh hi oh what's on your faces
uh of course they take many a bullet
there we go thank you could i ever take
anything that you have
what did that say polyclast skull what
does that even mean
what do you mean a poly crystal
of a powerful creature they well they
weren't very powerful
i'll tell you that much hello
who's here bam did i get everything
i did
this looks vaguely familiar plenty of
vents for me
i have to be kind of strong to be able
to rip anything off its hinges like that
i don't care if it's rusted down
i did not seem to put a lot of effort
into that also i am beating up like
giant werewolves that are two times my
size
and i'm having equally matched fights
with large women
i've got to get upstairs what the hell
is all of that going on over there
what is city 17 what is this a citadel
a half-life all right whatever you say
man
also what the hell do i do with all the
money you've been giving me
oh yeah i'm not gonna question this
thanks to your consistent patronage i've
expanded my services
okay good oh good i was just thinking of
ways to pass the time
good yes good good yes i don't have
nearly enough fish for that and i don't
have
juicy game where can i get more fish
movement speed increases permanently
that'd be pretty dope yellow quartz
i'm gonna hold off because i know that
there's got to be like something that
combines with something with that
little and often fills the purse as they
say
oh what is that v61 whoa
w870 wow okay that's what i do with all
the money that you've been giving me but
i can't afford any of that but that's
an okay selection you're an interesting
selection
oh man where did all these other weapons
shotgun that's a shotgun are you
that that that's a shotgun
whoa man
all right fine then be that way you you
have fun with those i don't know when
i'm gonna get those
let me know if you'd like to strengthen
your weapons oh
i would ah if only you had the funds
ah it's all good i don't need it
i don't need it please come again oh
come as many times as i want
um b4 materials is that where i am now
or is that what's
i'm looking for oh it's a elevator where
are is this an
is this the yellow is this an elevator
wait wait a minute wait wait a minute
wait
wait wait wait wait
no people
i can't use it right now okay that makes
sense all right whatever the mysterious
voice in here please go to hell and die
that'd be really great if you could do
that right now
go whisper
i'm coming for you i'm gonna get you i'm
gonna shoot you in your face
who's there who's oh hi
[Applause]
i did it i'm the great oh hi
all right
[Applause]
seems like their head hit box is pretty
generous i kind of appreciate that
i do i really appreciate that hello
uh-huh interesting anybody through there
hello well
a little spooky but not too spooky i've
definitely seen spookier
what is hey there's no need there's no
need
we're all friends here except we're very
much
not friends but we could be friends
okay all right so far so good
all right they're just giving me a lot
of money
which i do appreciate but also i could
always use more bullets
whoa what is that well i don't have that
once i'm just in the way of whoa i don't
even know what the casting machine
okay that's gross
oh
yeah kind of gross don't know what
that's about
also i'm going to pretend like i don't
hear all that hissing
locked from the other side of course it
is just like everything in this place
hi bang
yeah the hitboxes are very generous
got you
i know i should probably save my higher
powered guns but i'm i'm sitting pretty
on a lot of things
on the power all right well that's a
concern okay
hi i don't like this
i don't like that at all oh you're from
the x-ray i've seen your picks
i've seen your pictures oh that doesn't
look good
hi bud how you doing you breathing
doesn't look like it okay cool i trust
that i trust that 100
wow you're still there
okay
yeah no i'm not sticking around nope
nope not sticking around okay nope
nope nope 100 nope what is this what is
this a lockpick
lockpick what is it lockpickable oh you
better hurry with that
oh you better oh you better hurry with
it yellowcards okay cool hey what's up
buddy
hey how you doing buddy hey how's it
going buddy
oh let me put this in the mold i'll
where's the relief mold here we go okay
plop that in
okay a little speedy on this would be
great
a little faster
okay thank you okay thank you thank you
thank you i got it i got a horse
seems useful it sure do don't it blap
perfect ah oh
oh do i need to grab that oh i don't i
need the
other molds properly
oh i don't have this yeah i know it's
locked
yeah i can see that very clearly it's
locked i don't have a key to any of that
okay whatever it's locked oh this locked
everything's locked
magnum ammo i'll take that okay i'll go
down the scary place
this seems very scary am i supposed to
shoot these oh yeah
you know i am
okay don't
oh who's grunting
you really gotta cut the moaning bros
whoa
hey bud
should have done that from the start oh
my god
i think i got him ah god damn it of
course
oh i hate you so much i hate you so much
oh i hit you i dislike you a lot
i dislike you a lot i dislike you a lot
what i was going to do is i was going to
use this to blow that because i
feel like this would be a better use
than five well
five bills probably would have been a
fair exchange for
taking care of that but i did it anyway
so it's too late
then now that that's clear bam [ __ ]
no all right you wanna go you wanna go
let's go okay you fell over
[ __ ] all right does this one need to
stop
bam all right i don't know why i did
that but [ __ ] you heisenberg that's why
i did that
shut up and go away whatever your drill
monster is i don't even want to know
what kind of fetish you're working with
that thing for
too too mature for playground insults
like that
i'm sorry heisenberg he seemed like a
reasonable dude except for the fact that
he seemed to want to kill me but even
that's probably reasonable
where's me in all this like seriously
where is mia in all of this
like when is mama bear gonna come screw
screaming out oh no oh oh no oh no oh no
no no no no
okay
well that looks like a thing
nice
oh oh that's good got that
now what do we do with that
kind of dark in here it's kind of dark i
can't really see
missing a cog of course it is
crazy be the cog all right
please give me the heebie-jeebies
it's the perfect opportunity for
something to come jumping out of you
okay mechanical soldier sold that
version one
fully grown male corpse used removed
heart implanted cadu
muscle stimulation via electric shock
was successful brain dead so no high
cognitive ability only moves by
destructive instinct
then stops could just made a zombie
apparently 1.01 attach headgear to the
cranium electrodes confirmed stable
brainwaves experiment one lycan fight
was dismantled and eaten within three
minutes issues with destructive and
murderous capabilities
yeah 1.1 1.10 replace lower part of arm
with drill not enough output for
effective movement need live bodies
perhaps
one point one five implant a cado
reactor in the chest output greatly
increased experiment two lycan fight
destroyed lycan
three lycans in one minute good results
but issues with reactor durability
may stop functioning if the reactor is
destroyed
that's a good that's a good hint there
buddy
that's good pal good good yeah good pal
tell me more pal friend
i think there's more in here hello oh
that's handy
thank you little thing nope this there
we go
all right back to the mold maker
don't don't don't don't don't do it
don't do it don't do it
all right you wanna you wanna go bro i
can hit that reactor
did i hit it oh damn it oh you're smart
aha oh [ __ ]
there we go are you not how are you not
oh [ __ ]
is that it come on you're gonna get it
bam
how oh how oh god i do not need to fight
you
i really don't i know i don't
miss me by that much my dude
there you go that's what you get oh
i'm fine i'm the winner you suck okay
where was the cog
i'm guessing this is the cog
oh yeah i didn't do this not enough
power and still not enough power
there's never going to be enough power
oh god
i'll go back to the dude sell some of my
skulls
talk to him maybe get some emotional
support about all this
hey duke why don't any zombies try to
kill you
why does no one seem to mention your
existence
you okay buddy
oh hi
ah yes yes
okay fine sorry did i bother you i wake
you up
ooh that's the sixth
oh my god this freaking shotgun
like that's so dope but why
why do you have that good deal
if i say so myself yeah you paid me a
lot of money okay we're gonna keep going
also what kind of super soldier program
were they running here
this is clearly some super soldier
[ __ ]
there's clearly some kind of operation
going on here how old is the umbrella
corporation
how long have they been doing this stuff
because those that like if it's carved
into a mountainside or if there's like
granite relics that have to do with the
freaking
umbrella corporation they must have been
around forever they're trying to say
that they're kind of the illuminati in
all of this
because if they are that's kind of cool
but i'm still trying to wrap my head
around everything that's actually
happening around here
you know why is chris working with them
no i don't have anything here
oh cog cog where was a cog i know there
was a cog
i saw cog i showed you my cog please
respond
yeah i'm still curious about how chris
matches up with all this because it just
does seem out of character for him to be
working for the umbrella corporation
for whatever reason like why would he
what would make him turn like that i
don't know
cog cog
got it perfect backup generator let's do
it give me the power baby
thank you thank you very much for that
really greatly appreciated
wonderful i can actually see oh god no
oh [ __ ] oh hey
okay all right yeah yeah such a
disappointment uh-huh uh-huh you tell me
i thought join forces against that [ __ ]
miranda
truly make a move
[Applause]
she locked us away in the village
decades of being forced to serve her
can you even understand
that humiliation
uh yeah i kind of can because it's kind
of the same thing you're trying to do to
me man but you know
like my siblings i want nothing more
than to be free of that
[ __ ] so i need power
the strong will destroy the weak that's
the way the world
you should have never refused me ethan
oh god damn it
nice like clockwork now although i'm
running out of snipey bullets
can i stab these yeah hey yeah
all right good what did that do what did
i leave in here so much stuff i bet
let me go through here once more before
i go forward
where does this go
oh yeah i've got a lot of craftable
whoa oh [ __ ] did that get you
ha ha
there you go that's more like it
where are you all coming from anyway
can i get everything in here no still
more stuff in here
man i don't know how much stuff i passed
in my time playing this game but it's
got to have been a lot
it had to have been a whole heaping hell
of a lot
i'm just not very observant but i'm
gonna keep moving forward anyway because
i'm an ignorant [ __ ]
hello ah thank you
hmm that looks like something i could
spring on someone
oh hey what's up let me spring something
on you come here i want to spring you
yeah come here come on come on yeah come
on oh over here yeah
okay yeah just a little closer a little
more and uh spring
has sprung that didn't seem to hurt you
at all
it's supposed to spring you
turns out the only thing that sprung was
bullets from my gun
that costs just as many bolts as it
would normally cost who
the hell
wow oh god no
i know i take reduced damage from uh
attacks now so i'm probably pretty beefy
i'm probably pretty tough but pretty
strong
hello what's this about
why would you have just a room here you
have to have a reason for this
oh hey dude what's up what's up pal
maybe i could chuck a
pipe bomb over here actually let me do
that little preemptive pipe bomb action
nah i don't have any
you in this round buddy but next time
i'm gonna open a can of whoop ass all
over you
where the hell am i why okay well
oh two oh interesting
damn it oh my god are you kidding me
oh he's got it in his back this is
highly ineffective
okay well this is very ineffective can i
sneak by you here buddy can i sneak by
you
oh boy
really really buddy hal
how about i just i'm just i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
push you away it doesn't work it
doesn't freaking work
there you go poof large
largo well thank you for that and what's
in here
shotgun not enough i'm i've i had a
surplus of snipey bullets and now i have
a
definitely missing some
thank you i could have ran i don't know
why i keep stopping and fighting
everything i don't need to
and yet i do anyway hey buds how you
doing man it would be tough to
stop all of you maybe this dude's making
all these soldiers just so he can
fight mother miranda whoever the hell
she is
whatever the hell she can do
i'm sure that her powers are very
profound and interesting
uh hello um
okay ah
no no no no no no and
can i
guys kind of an [ __ ] what are you
going to do
you're going to slice me yeah idiot
oh yeah where are you where is he
come on hit me
gotcha
well thanks for the contribution oh i
didn't know that thing recharged or else
i would have used it again
i still don't know where i'm going i'm
only hoping that i'm going the right
direction
which i seem to be going okay
it's amazing how they build all these
interiors to be perfect mazes
very good planning
holy crap okay yeah no no
no let's no no let's yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's go let's go
yes please and then close it maybe you
know close close
close it oh no i'm i'm just safe okay
glad i knew that without turning around
am i safe am i safe
probably safe hey here i am hey
buddy you want to come up the floor
hal
there was a door down there that i
didn't open am i not able to go back
down
welcome welcome you're sure to find
something new am i welcome am i
sure to find something new doesn't look
like it
maybe some of this maybe one of these
i can see why you'd be interested in
that can you
but can you see why kids love cinnamon
toast crunch
thank you for that do you think i would
buy such things i don't know what good
deal if i say so myself which one is it
those are two conflicting things
all right thank you so much for your
patronage and thank you all so much for
watching
be sure to check out distractable i
don't know if i've mentioned it already
but if i haven't and i don't think i
have
there's a link down in the description
below if you want some laughs with bob
wade and i
you know the series that we do together
we've taken all of our insanity and put
it into a podcast which just means that
we put it into audio format so that you
can listen to it on the go
link is in the description check it out
link down description
down there click that link click it now
click it now or else i will come after
you and i will be in your closet tonight
thank you i won't but maybe i will thank
you everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video bye-bye